do you feel and i've always wanted to
ask you this do you feel
asian like does it feel asian when you
wake up no no no that's a that's a funny
thing that's a good question dude that's
ridiculous is it really yeah because i
wake up i don't even think about it
really yeah this is what the first i i
think what time is it
every time i wake up what time is it
right and then i go that's what i think
where's my phone is the second thing
yeah and then the third thing is i gotta
pee yeah me too then the fourth thing is
i need to get some coffee or something
yeah i need something to get me up or
water or something she came through the
liquids yeah something like any liquid
right
then the fifth thing is am i asian
no
like i was the one people thought was
weird
i remember in in in middle school not
even in elementary school i lived in
minnesota
and the kids used to
throw not snowballs at my head but ice
rocks oh wow
and they just used as hard as they can
just throw it at my [ __ ] hat why you
collected them or something no i don't
no one collects ice rocks like oh people
were being mean
people being mean [ __ ] my bad man you
had an icicle collection at my home you
said you were the weird guy
i could see you collecting and people
were like here's another one and they
threw it on my head yeah and it hits my
head and i go thanks
well this one's shaped like rosie
o'donnell
no dude
no they used to do it violently
i'm sorry man
i would never do that to you dude if you
were my friend i know you wouldn't i
probably would have put you in like one
of those little wagons you know
there's red wagons yeah i know the right
way yeah it's a chinese buddy on the
side of it
i love you i love you too no i really do
love you i love you too as a human being
and i love you too and does that feel
good or no yeah i believe you you do
believe me yeah i was lying
i was good acting
i don't really have any feelings yeah
yeah yeah you're a piece of [ __ ] you're
a piece of [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah that was
like if you died i would just be like
what
leo died i'd be like oh
okay
just move on with my day so love is in
the air you guys have been lovers for
how long
and this is her sixth six years of
loving wow
and when was the first time that you
guys if it's okay to talk about it when
was the first time you guys had sexual
intercourse um probably
two months no that's not true a month
into our release
did you really yeah
i went she she didn't even come to my
place for a month did he uber did he
drive i drove to [ __ ] long beach
every day i'm asking the woman
he drove down there he did and what
would he do he's filth either he didn't
try to he didn't try he didn't clean his
car
he had piles of like bottles and just
dirty underwear everything
bro it's so gross but i was like okay
well i i respect that this is his
baseline and he's not trying to front
like he's anybody else oh that's pretty
cool yeah so there was no bait and
switch huh
there are a few but more of a
more of a maybe an effort thing not
really a cleanliness thing from the
get-go i knew he was a he was a pig hi
hi you know hygiene wise it was a
hygiene risk they call it yeah for sure
hepatitis risk oh
yeah yeah definitely wow um so you guys
the full one month then you guys got
into sex now how did that kind of start
because i'm or where was the first date
let's cause i just want to learn about
love it's valentine's i want to learn
about y'all's love
we can talk about love
what are you
see i bet a lot of people that have
deficiencies and stuff like that what do
you mean immediately think you're their
guy you know what i'm saying like
i could see somebody with like a vitamin
deficiency or like severe
you know uh dna deficiency or something
immediately being like a chromosome
deficiency being like oh this is our guy
you know this is our mayor
you know this is our wizard of oz
you don't like that at all
come on guys little guy but i want to
say this you know what you know the guy
can just say this guy yeah it's your
tone man is it really is sometimes your
tone dude yeah yeah man
that's it my bad
i think some people like to be on
cruises some people like
buffets i mean i have a friend that goes
on cruises
oh really he never even goes outside and
looks at the water or anything he just
stays in the boat and just goes to the
buffet because it's 24 hour buffet i
love buffets i love when they have a
honeycomb really yeah they don't have
regular honey they have honeycomb oh
honeycomb
what do you mean expensive where is that
yeah hawaii
yeah that sounds dancing
yeah
i don't know
go to ralph's
where do you think honey comes from bro
i know where honey comes from trees
brother
that's sad bro
we're talking about sap dude we get
naked
and they both just start cackling oh wow
with laughter when they see my body
but i'm laughing too right
but i did it anyway but the whole time
why you never you've seen your body
before they've never seen my body though
right but what are you laughing at
because they're laughing at my body oh
okay they're laughing so hard it makes
me want to laugh i think you're waiting
your whole life to see your body and
this is when you decided to do it
no no that's not it
i had seen my body do i have mirrors
where did you say honey comes from what
was your honeycomb the woods
yeah in the woods but in honeycomb yeah
honeycomb yeah where did that come from
you kook you come you want to call me
goocon
i do not
yes you did and we have it on [ __ ]
factual files dude
okay that's not a real thing factual
style i like that actual file i feel
like that's something we should um hash
out right mullet versus mullet dale
um well there's nothing you know i'll be
honest with there's no hash out to be
happened you know it's like you know a
friend of mine
right showing it always relaxing
you know a friend of mine dude oh you
have that native yours is more native
yeah my name is
mine is definitely a little bit more
british one guy with a drum in front of
me you know yeah yeah yeah i got more
yeah in front of me dude somebody throws
something somebody throws a freaking
pineapple over your shoulder or
something somebody throws a yeah it's
more native somebody throws a spear yeah
somebody carves you up and makes a
[ __ ] chubby soup you know
how do you do a lot dude
you run out of [ __ ] to talk talk about
or what what podcast yeah i mean i i
don't know i'm blanking today dude are
you really yeah well let's talk about
stevie
we'll talk about whatever i want to talk
about you know man well you just said
you had nothing then i know but i just
want to see what happens
i just want to see what happens when
this don't be the aggressive person with
nothing
yeah i just want to see what happens
when this thing turns on but did you
don't watch game of thrones
no i don't watch that kind of stuff
what do you mean just people fighting in
the past and all of that
wait i'm more like is that a historical
document about the past
is it something that really happened no
it's not
yeah i don't watch elizabeth no it's not
that kind of stuff bro well i'm not sure
maybe i'll read up on it a little bit no
no no look at me no no no i know when
you know what dude
i'm tired dude i'm tired too man what
time is it i know
i know my arms hurt too no no you're
gonna do a couple more minutes yeah i am
you're gonna do a couple more minutes
while i grill you okay grow away dude i
will dude all right i am i'm tired of
your [ __ ] wake up with the king honest
dude's [ __ ] making burgers over here
yeah yeah i'm tired of your [ __ ] right
cause you like to you know what you like
to do
you like to distract me
i do yeah [ __ ] word games dude no i
do not yeah you do no yeah you do
techniques don't do that again either
what is that take this away from a
couple yeah piece of glass you have too
much morning blitz way too much warning
[Music]
i'm tired of carrying a wallet in my
back pocket because for me it just feels
i don't know
archaic and uncomfortable i don't like
people looking at my back of my pants
and being like oh is that guy a camel
you know look at the lump in his pants
so now you gotta work with that new
front pocket carry and whoa
oh
my god
[Music]
whoa that was a dark wow dude that's
real it was just crazy that we're adults
and this is it
it's a great show
i think you'd really like it
it's like i in terms of pop culture i
think there's not a better show out
there
but tiger belly no i mean game of
thrones oh yeah i haven't seen it i know
you have it
wow
i don't see what are you doing
no i'm not going to let him do it he's
not going to groundhog yeah you have a
little different i know what you're
doing defense mechanisms that you do
right and then you try to divert me and
i go oh yeah okay i guess
it's like jedi minds but i'm jab off
it doesn't work with me
you're [ __ ] [ __ ] i didn't do it i
don't see that
yeah i'm not accusing you of doing
anything dude oh my god i don't know
you're not a dummy
you're a bright young puppy you watch it
who's this little [ __ ] uh white dude
you have here man that's premature nick
dude he was a premature baby
i can tell man can you a little yeah his
head is like misshapen whoa
yeah that's not true he's handsome he's
handsome he's really handsome no he's
got a point i shaved my head in eighth
grade and i got a lumpy lumpy head i can
tell that grandma was mad yeah
it's like god um god when he was making
you man he was in a rush
right like
when he made brad pitt right he spent
like three weeks right yeah like you
know like and then with you it was like
and then sent them down here the sketch
was good but the final product yeah the
sketch was good i think it was some
issues yeah it was like an early factory
deal that they had yeah god when they
made me he made like 3 000 of me at the
same time you know what pep and we're
all made and it came we came down here
yeah yeah you know what sweetie you have
some really thick legs thank you
he does thank you let's start female
thick
where's george like that george we're
starting george
yeah like that young kind of
high school thing wow no hair at the top
of your legs either no
oh
[ __ ]
wow
you're doing the kendall jenner keep
doing it yeah
you should get that cut off huh what is
that
that's a fupa oh you got to get that cut
off from donated huh a black friend told
me that chinese people are like the
black people of asia is that true or is
that what is that have you ever heard
that
do you just say
chinese people
are the black people of asia yeah
yeah
aside from the fact they don't have
black dicks chinese don't bro who's
going who who's got that large meat on
the asian side oh filipinos for sure
because they're mixed in with like oh
yeah
yeah dude because the spanish because
they were like invaded so much occupied
bro that like you know you get debated
enough you'll get outvated a little
right yeah the spanish
filipino hole oh you know how babies are
making oh yeah yeah right and they
squirt inside right
right so you know they were colonized
places that are colonized are mixed in
with [ __ ]
i wish black
african nations colonized more yeah
because maybe i'd have a bigger dick
they do a little bit they have the
barclays center if you've seen that